thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show Shelly is in Austin
Texas
hi Shelly how are you hi Dave I'm a
little nervous I'm so excited I'm
getting to talk to you I can't believe
this well me too how can I help
I well I have a situation that was just
presented to me recently by an
acquaintance that I go to church with
and he passed on to me a pamphlet from
World Financial Group about a business
opportunity for women and it's done a
lot of marketing information in it about
how women can break the glass ceiling
and so on and so forth and I did a
little bit of research online about the
company and it looks to me to be like a
multi-level marketing division of maybe
I know there are another a large company
that year they owned several like
Transamerica and some other casino
nationwide insurance and some other
companies that we know by name and from
I guess I'm just calling to seek your
advice I was kind of considering it as
maybe going in as I'm currently on my
own business on a maid service which is
a lot of hard work but I was looking at
this is possibly a part-time opportunity
and that I've net I don't have any
experience with these multi-level
marketing companies and what's involved
with them as a job opportunity and so I
just thought I would seek your advice
okay well let's talk about multi-level
marketing or network marketing as is
sometimes called just in general before
we talk about oral financial multi-level
marketing in general is is fine there's
nothing wrong with it in essence the the
upside is is that you are obviously
selling out there in the marketplace you
control your destiny there is no glass
ceilings there's no um it's kind of the
wild wild west whatever you can figure
out to get done you get done within the
guidelines on how you get paid at that
company
and you know there have been people that
have made serious money in those
overtime and I know people that make
over a million dollars and four or five
different ones okay and so they're in
that sense there's a there's a
legitimacy to it it's a real thing so
most people call it a pyramid scheme or
something like that it's not a pyramid
scheme pyramid scheme that the last man
standing gets nothing and that's not
true of a true multi-level because a
product is actually being sold in their
the from a technical standpoint or a
legal standpoint then that's kind of a
good side of the multi-level the bad
side of the multi-level is you need to
understand the business that you are in
and if you understand that business
you're okay and the business you're in
is not the financial business in this
case or whatever they do the business
you're in is recruiting okay and your
recon stantly recruiting recruiting
recruiting everyone is a recruit and and
so if you don't recruit people because
your fallout is very very hot the vast
majority of the people that are
recruited into multi-level are gone
within three four months but certainly
within a year almost nobody's there okay
a year-long person in your hierarchy in
most of these things is very rare now
when you get one of those and they go
build their own hierarchy of course
that's where some serious money starts
to happen right and I'm sorry that
excuse me so you're not making money
selling financial services not if you
want to make not if you want to make
more than minimum wage okay because
you're going to be you know in the case
of Amway you're not making money selling
the products that Amway sells you're
making more money getting people on your
team that get people on their team they
get people on their team they get people
on their team okay and and so your
hiring and training a high turnover
sales force if you want to make some
money you're not going to make a hundred
thousand dollars a year in a multi-level
organization working three hours a week
if someone told you
that's a lie right okay nothing does
that that's illegal yes to me that to me
that's common sense
I'm just from that but some of these
people run around hyping and they say
you know here's my check I made a
hundred thousand dollars last month yeah
we did
but when you'd understand you know
you've been fighting this thing and
you're a great recruiter and a great
sales trainer and you're growing a large
large organization and that's how that
happens it doesn't just happen by going
door-to-door selling stuff yeah and so
that you got to understand if you want
to get in the sales training and
recruiting business that's what you're
doing you're fine now I don't know much
about World Financial Group there's
something running around in the back of
my head and I gotta have to go look it
up that's ringing a real negative Bell I
have had I have read some negative
things about that I can't remember what
it is that they were doing but there was
something they were doing that was like
a it was a tax avoidance I think it was
like the income tax is not a valid tax
and we can show you how not have to pay
your income tax there was one group
doing that and I'm not sure that's this
group but there's a group running
through the church is called something
world something that did that a few
years ago I hadn't heard from him in a
while
so I kind of thought they went out of
business but it was something along
those lines and so if they're doing that
stuff stay away from them right guys
income tax you know it wasn't ratified
by the last state so it's not
constitutional at all this bunch of crap
hey they put 3,000 people in jail last
year for not paying their income tax
don't be out there involved in something
like that yeah I know so um yeah you
know and I gotta tell you I really
questioned and I don't know but as soon
as I hear it my my BS meter goes off
when it's they say they own nationwide
yeah it might be more like there's a
conglomerate that owns nationwide that
also owns them and nation why it's huge
and they're a little wart on the end of
somebody's toe and I think that's that's
true day I'm sure I'm missing this place
that it's I think the company is and I
don't know if I'm fancy or every I think
it's a eg Oh in something like that I'd
have to
on the web I don't have it in front of
me right now but it seems to own yeah
yeah unless you were sitting around
before your friend came up to you and
thinking to yourself I'd really like to
be a sales trainer in the financial
world this is not a fit right and this
was totally unsolicited and I I have I
have a mortgage process or an
underwriter background I was in that
industry for almost 20 years and I
decided I didn't want to sit in capable
anymore and I went to own my own
business but for know we're doing that
well I think I would have my time I got
personally put my time into that right
is what I would do and just because what
I was thinking and I and I trust your
advice and I just wanted to call him see
what you had to say okay thanks for the
call well that's the lowdown on the
multi-level marketing so sometimes
people say Dave's anti multi-level not
really I just call it like it is and
like it is is sometimes it's all hyped
up in a bunch of crap and it is a
recruiting business but is it legitimate
do I have friends then multi-level that
make them over million dollars here yeah
I do absolutely so you can't say it's
not legitimate it's illegal or something
like that I'll tell you where to people
do get put off by it a lot is the very
nature of multi-level is you recruit
someone to get to to use their
credibility to get their friends and
relatives and people kind of get tired
of that they get tired of hey I started
this new thing I want to come by and
show it to you you know calling up for a
meeting thing and and you know I've
gotten to where I'm honestly fairly
direct with people I try to be kind but
I'm fairly direct with them that are
friends and getting these things and so
now I kind of have a job I'm kind of
busy and I know you can't come by and
come by anytime
100% social and come by and see us and
say hi I've dinner with or something
like that but no I don't need to be
presented your business opportunity
there's no chance and so the some of the
problem is is when people get so on fire
they see every living breathing person
as a potential
recruit and so all their people then
their lives become transactions rather
than relations and that's a mistake it's
actually a bad way to run your
multi-level hierarchy to is to not
really assess who might really be good
at this instead of just did they pass
the mirror test and they fog up a mirror
and I know all the numbers I've seen
them on I've heard all the pitches and
the hype and stuff around it you never
know who's going to win I know that I
get all of that but I'm also understand
that many people view these things it's
just relationship rate or you just go
around and take advantage of all your
relationships they call it working their
natural market and folks get tired of it
so that's the resistance you're going to
run into when you're in one of those
things this is the Dave Ramsey show